a lot of recruiters and i've been very
mindful of this over the years go in and
they start selling to somebody oh i've
got the greatest job in the world and da
da da whereas i don't do that whether i
found that person on one of the back of
the job boards whether they've applied
for a job whether they've messaged me on
linkedin i do not sell a job i listen
first what is your situation what are
your frustrations what is the things you
love about your job what are the things
you'd hate if you could hand carve that
next job
what would it look like to you what
would it need you to do to enjoy mondays
so once you have that information you're
in a position of power because if they
say they hate new business and i've got
a new business role i'm not going to
tell them about it if they say well hang
carve this role and it's exactly what
i've got and it's right for them in
their personal circumstance then i'll
tell them about the job and the detail i
go in that i know about my clients
is like i work there you know it's not a
job spec that i'm reading off i've been
down i've visited the site i've
understood the management structure i've
understood the opportunities i've
understood what that role gives to that
person it's about finding all the
different elements that can work at the
minute and making sure you've got access
to all the job boards linkedin getting
all of those web crawlers and everything
and getting everyone into a long list
making sure that you've got the facility
to email everyone to say something text
them phone them because you've probably
got five or seven touch points before
you get hold of somebody at the moment
so anything that makes your life easier
be available to talk to people out of
hours because ultimately they don't need
that job right now this is on their
terms not on your terms and when you do
build a relationship with people you
know i've told some woman that i've
placed today that my kids have got these
debit cards at 11 years old go henry
that they can use in shops because she's
a mum that's going to go that's going to
make her life easier if you befriend
people and they understand you know that
i'm a working mum myself they're less
likely to ghost you even those people
that have let me down and not took jobs
they will come back to me because i've
built a relationship i think the people
that make recruitment transactional
they're the people that are struggling
to get those people over the line at the
moment because you have to build
relationships the recruitment mentors
podcast is proudly sponsored by vincerie
and the award-winning sauce breaker